as you know what I've had enough of fat
I don't know if I'm coming to the Masjid
and not finding anything for myself to
eat so tell me what is this place that
we're in so this is the kitchen okay
where we will be cutting up vegetables
and with scissors go ahead tell us we
will be cutting up the food over here
inshallah to serve the Muslims
and this is newly bought why the
donations of the people yes
this whole complex here where people can
get in our food and his father Masjid
yes it will be a big restaurant
inshallah for families to come with a
family sexually alhamdulillah
is this a bar is this a bar no but it's
not a bar it's like a ball to be huh
zamzam martinis or something maybe maybe
you you'll come and serve them bartender
okay so tell us so this is going to be
the area where they're going to be
eating it's a whole complex sale yeah
yeah and drinking food and for the kids
and everything this whole area here is
going to be the restaurant area this is
spacious yeah so this area over here
including this area over here it all
needs to reap be refurbished and rebuilt
as a beautiful restaurant I'm so proud
of the people that now look how physical
and tangible these things are this is
your donations right here
but I'm saying this is a tangible thing
when we're all dead and gone this will
be oh yes absolutely and the fact that
you still you see that there's a lot of
work to be done here yes it means that
this is a brilliant chance for you to
keep on donating yes and supporting this
amazing cause what are you taking us now
for her tell me so connected to the
restaurant there's one facility we
thought is really really important to
have in a Masjid yes and that's a
playground for the kids
so
I I personally haven't seen any Masjid
yes in the world I don't know of any
Masjid has a proper playground for the
kids so this will be a two three hundred
square meters area all for children all
for children to come and natural love
for the house of Allah because it is a
problem sometimes within musks and stuff
like that the children feel left out
alienated in fact sometimes they're told
off because they're playing around this
is a safe space for the child in the
mosque
will grant them you know the ability to
be closer to Allah in a way that
like you know the hadees of the seven
people under the Strait of Allah as a
young person who his heart is connected
to the message so it's beautiful and
this is amazing I really am proud of the
people I'm proud of you guys I am that
you are able to donate so generously
such that we can actually have something
like this and now it's not as you can
see it's a working progress and the
progress has been made but it needs to
be continually made which means that
guys
I'm going to ask you one more time it's
time again how could you let a situation
forego
a situation like this waste an
opportunity like this how how when it
could be in your scales you must click
the link below it's your time it's our
time and inshallah these will be
tangible things for all of us click the
link below now don't miss the
opportunity
foreign